hate parks and now you thought not
exhibition's better it was like it was
like okay hold on there's different
types of artex yeah okay okay there's
the pretentious kinds
finish that sentence show there's The
Pretender okay and the ones I like
there's the pretentious kinds and then
there's like the fun interactive kinds
okay I went to the fun interactive okay
good which one what are the pretentious
kinds you know the ones that are just
like the like look I'm gonna call them
out a lot of the Contemporary Arts
museums around the world that I've been
to are just like a little bit too like
you know this is odd I have nailed a
banana to the wall and I've called it
actually duct tape but honestly whatever
I would argue that they're all like that
though
um some of them are just more fun at all
I think I think older art museums are
pretty stunning yeah those ones those
ones are like the Rembrandt up close
yeah for sure that's [ __ ] stuff yeah
yeah yeah
um yeah I mean like we went to this into
I can't remember the name it was like
team Labs or something like oh yeah yeah
yeah you went to team last I went to
team it's like yeah that is like I am a
tourist in Japan yeah yeah every single
article about uh places to go in Japan
has teams has teammates I don't know
they've dominated the like tourism
you've been obviously all right yeah
I've never been you never no I mean I've
been like two or three times yeah
because like the only reason I was I was
there because like we were in the area
and we had like a like an hour or two
together I was like what's in the area
oh team laps let's let's go check it out
and it's it's weird right because it was
like the whole things about team Labs is
that there's it's this kind of like
interactive kind of our exhibition where
they have different pieces that most of
them you can interact with right for
Instagram huh for Instagram oh it is an
Instagram it is like it's literally
nobody nobody there actually cares about
the art I'll say that yeah everyone
there cares about getting a cool [ __ ]
person no one no one goes into a team
Labs room and goes I love the way that
the colors of represent presenting that
our internal start no they're just like
all right where is the prettiest
background for my next Instagram yeah I
I know this because I was the only one
actually [ __ ] reading the text with
every exhibition everyone was just like
just like I didn't even know there was
text
because like we we were like we we would
walk through this thing and I'd be like
and there would be like this text
explaining this art exhibition at the
end Sydney Sydney was always already in
the next [ __ ] room and I was like
wait a minute I'm reading this and then
I read it and then I'm like okay now I
understand why no one reads this yeah
because like it was okay that it's it's
Instagram bait disguised as an art
museum yeah of course that's what it is
like it's it's made for Instagram and so
yeah people taking pictures which is
fine nothing wrong with that but like
yeah pretending to be some pretentious
art museum is kind of like well I mean
you know I went to meow wolf uh on the
US tour which is basically the American
version of Team Labs so it's like it's
it's an interactive Art Museum but no
one actually gives a [ __ ] about like the
art so what was in meow wolf so meow
wolf is very much similar to team labs
in the sense that like it's separated
into like different rooms so like each
room I don't know how it is in team Labs
but at least with meow wolf at least the
one I went to in uh in Denver was um
each room is actually done by a
different independent artist so the vibe
and the feel of everything and the
interactivity and the level of
interactivity is completely different in
different rooms yeah um so and there
isn't usually like one theme of the
entire place it's it's like all over the
[ __ ] place whereas like team Labs is
kind of like the theme I feel like kind
of flows into one another so it feels
like just one big exhibition right and
then lots of little small exhibitions
right
um and I feel like at least at least
meow wolf is a lot more like I don't
know it's kind of like teen Labs on
crack it's just like it's just sensory
overload right whereas team Labs is a
little more like subtle and more like
ambient in in its feel right it's like
oh okay this is kind of a nice calming
environment that is also very aesthetic
and Instagram worthy yeah because uh
there are some exhibitions where there
are some pieces where I was just like
I'll be honest I don't get it like there
was there was one exhibition where you
had to like take your shoes off because
there's there's a lot a lot of Team Labs
um there are some exhibitions where I
can get up to like knee-high water yeah
yeah and here I am working like boots on
the [ __ ] jeans and I'm like oh I'm
going to have a bad time but luckily I
could just roll my jeans up it's pretty
cool though yeah it's very cool but that
was like one exhibition where the the
exhibition is you walking up uh you
walking up like a slight incline and
then there's like warm water trickling
down oh yeah mind you this water doesn't
smell like spring water it's very
clearly chlorine water yeah so it just
smells like swimming pool right because
God knows how many people are walking in
this water and then I remember I
remember like oh this is this is a cool
entrance to an exhibition right this is
a cool entrance to whatever they're
about to show us and then I walk up uh I
reach the top of the hill
um I've reached the next room and then
there's a plaque explaining that that
was the exhibition I was like what I
thought that was like the entrance to
the yard piece I didn't know that was a
[ __ ] art piece itself what was the
explanation that we've made a [ __ ] River
yeah it was it worth the money would you
say
um if you post on Instagram I didn't
take any pictures
did you really go can't wait hold on
you are I think you are the only person
I've ever heard of that has gone to team
labs and not taken a photo literally the
only person on Earth to ever go there
and I'll take a picture yeah I took
photos with Sydney uh
[Music]
but then there was like another there
was like another RP's as well where it
was basically this room that was just it
was padded from like ceiling to like
floor and like all the walls padded with
like bean bags and stuff like that and
you could like you you couldn't like
walk on it
uh without [ __ ] falling over or
something because like you it was just
so well padded that you would sink in
and like the whole point of that is that
um I can't remember what's the message
okay I'll I'll try and remember what the
message was because I was reading this
and I was just like this is I I I don't
[ __ ] get this so it's like uh since
the World is Flat we've forgotten that
we can affect each other right so when
so hold on did you just start off with
the World is Flat
since we since was this made by flano
so we all know the world is
or a flat floor it forgets the effect we
can have on our fellow human being
um so because the message I got because
I remember that room the message I got
out of that room is oh it's like a
McDonald's playpen this is fun the
message I got of that room is twitchcon
could [ __ ] never man switch con could
never
this is what swisscon wanted
they didn't have enough phone for this
[ __ ] what
was it I think I remember one of the the
cool rooms in team Labs I think it was
like uh it was covered it was this kind
of hallway that was covered in like very
very light strings just like yeah that
was the coolest one that had like lights
attached to it and the lights would kind
of like Flicka and like wave back and
forth as you were like kind of wait
waving through this like sea of lights
that was really cool what's the message
behind that I don't know that was that
was I I just I just remember going
through a lot of like the exhibitions in
team Labs
um
that's always thought of it like this is
like the penultimate scene where Jonah
gets to kill like the the main bad guys
like bodyguard right and then it's
always in like one of those art things
right it's like everything's
everything's a mirror yeah it was
reflective and there's lights and he's
almost gonna fight them there was a room
in meow wolf actually where the entire
thing was just full of mirrors yeah it's
just I just like it's pretty cool
they've been pulling that trick since
like a circus stage in the 1900s I know
but I've never been in one and so when I
went in one I was like oh this is true
mirrors never what that's like every
like shitty Carnival has one I never
went to a carnival they don't have
Carnival they don't have shitty
carnivals in Australia maybe they do but
my parents never took me a while
yeah I think I think my biggest takeaway
after going out of like that like
interactive art experience is that it's
a [ __ ] travesty that you would make
this in the country where every [ __ ]
uh every drug is illegal it's just like
it's it's a it's a natural [ __ ]
travesty you know like yeah
that is true
that's funny it's like it's like you
don't need drugs just use your
imagination
and read the writing on the walls that
no one [ __ ] reads because because I'm
going through it and I'm like this this
is an exhibition that just was seemed to
be made for like a country where you you
pop an edible or something ago and you
go enjoy the experience you know that's
that just it just seems like that was
what this experience was Taylor Made for
and obviously that's that's not a thing
in Japan so no man museums in Japan are
either like amazing or so so bad and
normally they're bad what's a good
Museum
I think a good museum is one that where
you know nothing of the source material
or what it's based on or what it's what
it's there to cover and it can engage
you yeah so I think like you know have
you been to the Natural History Museum
in the UK that's really good like I
don't [ __ ] care about dinosaurs maybe
I'm maybe I'm like the one person I
don't know I don't know I don't care
about dancing people say they don't care
about dinosaurs but no one like no one
actively like deep down there is the
five-year-old you that's the yeah
Tyrannosaurus
don't give a [ __ ] someone says they
don't care about dinosaurs I'm like bet
there's there's a bone in your body
that's just like it's like a really like
everything in that museum is so well
made and all the information is
presented in such a really cool way yeah
you know when you go into like the
dinosaur exhibition it's you literally
walk in and all of these like elements
explaining everything about dinosaurs
and stuff yeah literally above you is a
giant [ __ ] like dinosaurs like
skeleton yeah yeah really cool Rick and
packed it's just really busy because
dinosaurs are cool because dinosaurs are
sick and even like even like the stuff
where it's like the the Bug Museum part
of it I'm like that's [ __ ] sick yeah
that's awesome no I like given there are
some topics that are easier to present
uh in museums than others I think
animals like one of the easier ones yeah
yeah but like something like ass is like
I'm like [ __ ] I don't I don't know how
you would get me interested in that I I
had it I've been to our galleries before
yeah
um
and it's uh let's just say it's not for
me you know that's just what's a really
popular Museum I really I'm gonna I'm
like [ __ ] man I wish this was quiet but
then when I get in a really quiet Museum
like [ __ ] I'd love some something like
some just some cough or something yeah
there's something there's like a balance
of like the the amount of people in an
exhibit right like because I remember
like I don't have I I don't really have
time to do it anymore but I remember
when I first moved to Japan I had this
like period of like six or seven months
where I used to go to the the you know
the Mori Arts Museum in Roppongi there's
this there's this art museum in Roppongi
uh like in roponky Hills where the old
YouTube headquarters used to be oh is
that um where they have that weird like
a [ __ ] like stranger things ass
monster thing looking statue yeah the
spider yeah right [ __ ] creepy
whatever that thing is but basically on
the top floor of uh one of the buildings
there they have this thing called the
moriarts museum and I think it's like
every somewhere the anime stuff goes a
lot of animes I went to the I went to
the almost Neverland one yeah oh I was
like I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
yeah but basically it's like I think
it's like every couple of months they
switch out the exhibits to like new
things sometimes it's like anime
exhibits sometimes it's you know just
like uh an independent artist sometimes
it's like maybe like dinosaurs or
something thematic yeah and I had a
period for like uh maybe like the first
year or so where I would go to the
moriarts museum like every other month
just to see what was there because I
think the way that they did it was
really cool because it's like obviously
if it was like an anime Museum like I
went to the attack on Titan Museum there
and like the Sailor Moon exhibit there
and like those they did a ton of those
um but then there was somewhere it's
just like an independent artist where
it's like I've never the heard of this
person or what they do but let's go
check it out and I think the moriarts
museum does it in a cool way because
it's kind of like a lot of it is like a
lot of Contemporary Arts where it's kind
of like team Labs where it's it's not
necessarily interactive but it kind of
is is it isn't just like here's some
paintings on a wall yeah you know it's
very much like sculptures or like whole
room exhibits or like you know something
to do with like lighting or something
like that where it's like a little more
interesting than just being like yeah so
the the paintwork on this is is
exquisite you know it's like and it's
like I don't have a problem with that
kind of Art Exhibit as well like I've
been to the Louvre and stuff like that
and a lot of it is like that but like
there's more history behind that right
yeah and that's that's the interesting
part to me yeah I mean that with those
kinds that's more like a museum yeah in
my mind because you're seeing like
actual real history you're single
kind of experiencing a part of history
and stuff like that yeah and you know
there has been art that has like
impressed me and stuff like that but I
feel like one you really need to be in
the right mood to be there because then
you know you need to be on the right
drugs
depending on who you're asking
yeah because like unless there's some
kind of interesting way to display this
information yeah no matter if you're if
it's like an art museum or if it's just
a museum about whatever right if it's
just this display and just text next to
it it's just that's I've I've never
found that interesting at all yeah it
feels like I'm just scrolling through a
Wikipedia article yeah you know I think
like one of the really cool ones I
remember going uh to seeing the moriarts
uh Museum was uh this independent
Japanese contemporary artist who does a
lot of like uh exhibits and paintings
but all of her Works uh kind of play
around with like this idea of
perspective yeah so there's like there
was a piece I remember the black and
white one uh I don't know if it's the
black and white one but there was one
where like one of the rooms you walk
into and the entire room looks like the
inside of a train but when you look on
either side of the walls the walls are
actually like skewed in so it so when
you look straight down it it looks like
the wall goes way further than it
actually does and it looks like you're
like actually looking down a carriage of
a train and like stuff like that is cool
because it's like it's again it's not
just like painting and some text yeah
you know if anything I think that
exhibit like that entire exhibit there
was no like text to read about it was
kind of just like a go see it for
yourself feel how you feel interpreted
how you interpret it and like post your
pictures yeah like you know it's I I
like the kind of exhibits where it's
like it gives you the space to interpret
how you want to interpret it like if you
want to find that to be cool then sick
if you just look at it and be like yeah
all right then you're free to do so kind
of thing you know because like what how
did feel about the anime art exhibits or
the manga exhibits that pop up every now
so yeah and because I've been to a lot
of them are you going to convince me
it's anything but a glorified way to get
exclusive merch I mean that is
definitely true I feel like that's why
like 90 people go to them yeah yeah yeah
that's why I go to 90
because I'm like I'm like I'm like
the original panels pretty dope yeah you
know like see like you know like when I
went to like the berserk exhibit for
example right I was like [ __ ] seeing
like Mira's art and [ __ ] like that was
like you know up close and personal was
[ __ ] amazing but I want that limited
edition painting though it's like every
time I see a new a new like anime or
Manga exhibit I'm like oh they decided
to do a pop-up store and an extra
exhibit on top of that you know it's
it's it's it's nice and I think berserk
is one of the few examples I think of
that could really work because mirror's
art is [ __ ] insane yeah and I think
it would be insane to see his original
manuscripts and everything like that
actually I think one of the best anime
exhibits I ever went to was probably the
Barky one uh that they did a Tokyo Dome
because it's like it's not only you get
to see like up close and personal you
know itagaki's like panels and you know
art and stuff like that but they also
had interactive elements so like in the
middle of the exhibit they basically
recreated like the the under the Tokyo
Dome like bad Model area with like full
on Sand and everything and that little
details of like little bits of like
teeth and nails like on the ground and
[ __ ] and like there's a statue of baki
that you can like stand next to and take
a photo with but it looks like you're
fighting Bucky in the underground like
stuff like that I think is makes
standard like anime exhibits way cooler
like it's still cool like if you like
the artist or you know you like the the
look of the manga whatever just going to
go see the original stuff as a fan is
dope but like it gives you more of an
excuse I guess to like you know actually
be part of the experience if you have
something there that's not just let's
just look at some manga panels you know
yeah yeah a lot of them that I've been
to are just literally like behind the
scenes panels and it's like okay if I'm
really into that that's cool yeah a lot
of times I'm kind of like okay well I
mean I kind of like that I've already
I've already seen it yeah I feel like
they're like oh it took him two days to
write this I'm like okay well but I need
to come here to find that out like right
right A lot of the times I'm just like
why go to a physical location like yeah
and cool yeah maybe some behind the
scenes or early panels or mock-ups
that's cool yeah like for me it's like
yeah you know yeah they're back you one
sounded cool I'm kind of said I didn't
go to it yeah yeah The Barking wants
what I didn't like about the Barky one
though is the fact that that the add-on
that they decided to tack onto it was a
Bucky themed Cafe which oh those they
always Japan does every single [ __ ]
time but like the Bucky one especially I
was like wow you guys took the laziness
of like incorporating the elements of
baki with standard Cafe food to the next
level they had like they had like
[ __ ] carbonara that was themed after
that's okay and I'm like
one there was not a single moment in
Baki where datsu is eating carbonara and
two when you look at the picture it's
literally just a plate of carbonara with
like a paper cut out of nitza's face Red
Sea the Chinese guy yeah the Chinese guy
okay oh okay and I'm like you weren't
even gonna like match with Chinese food
you gave him [ __ ] carbonara I think a
lot of the times I I'm just speculating
on how it works but I think a lot of
them are like outsourced cafes so it's
like whatever the cafe can make yeah for
sure so you just kind of like yeah
[ __ ] put their face on it but at
least like you know I've been to some of
them are good though yeah I've been to
some themey cafes where like the food
actually matches like the theme of
whatever it is like that's the reason
why it's easier though yeah like certain
shows lines way better to having
absolutely food than others yeah so I
totally get it but it's like at that
point if you're gonna go so far as to
like not even put the effort to like at
least try and get close to the theme of
whatever themed Cafe it is then like
what's the point in wasting your time
and money on it well
[Music]
I go to Every exhibition and I swear 90
of the people are waiting in the merch
line and it's like 10 are in the actual
exhibit exactly yeah when I I went to
the a bunch of few cafes Emma Leakes
Emily's obsessed with them yeah I don't
know how she's doing videos about them
and we went to the um I don't know I
almost follow a video they went to the
Banana Fish Cafe and there was there was
merch and my God it was like one of the
matches was that you could um you could
buy a pre-packaged cookie it's a cookie
like not but it's like it's like the
outside packaging is themed for like an
artist yeah I guess yeah because I guess
how much the cookie was
like literally a Starbucks cookie that
you could buy 400 Yen fibers like 900
Yen what the [ __ ] that's a cookie
that you're probably not gonna eat
because you don't want to ruin the past
it's just anything special no no you
should [ __ ] cookies it wasn't even
banana flavored I don't even think it's
bananas
uh and again like this food is always
just so meh yeah I hate going to these
places like I'm like I've wasted one of
my my color caloric intake meals on this
and I paid a premium for it if I I would
have rather have gone to McDonald's like
literally anything else like why I just
food is my one joy in life and these
cafes rob it from me and I get I get so
sad when I go to them yeah yeah which is
why I like I think I really appreciate
it when I do find a themed Cafe that
actually gives a [ __ ] about trying to
I've never been to one where I thought
the food was good okay because the only
one I've been to that I thought was good
was the Kirby Cafe I've heard that one's
pretty good actually yeah the booking is
like nuts you feel like like all the
semi-decent cafe with the book like 10
years in advance yeah like two months in
advance yeah the Pokemon but even then
like I've been to the Pokemon cafe a few
times and it's like the food is good
like it's better than the standard
themed Cafe but still it's like it's
[ __ ] in Cafe it's hard especially
when it's a pop-up too to make food
that's even remotely good because it's
well that's why the Kirby one is good
because that's a permanent one at right
yeah it's like a Sky Tree they have more
time yeah and it's like the food the
food items that they have and like how
they present it is actually matches the
theme of the Kirby Universe I'm like oh
they actually put some [ __ ] effort
into it and the merch is actually good